[Applause]
man
holy [__] this please whatever that is
this
oh my god really
that's what got me last time is I was
trying to desperately grab at things and
nothing was able to actually do anything
and that's how I did hello welcome back
to the glitched attraction I'm sure that
I'm safe now
I'm sure that I'm A-Okay so that should
give me enough time to look around this
room and actually figure out what I need
to do
here we go
is this
there we go that's what I needed
apparently
what what what
[Music]
what what what what
are we still going
okay so I need to get Gears
was that just the beginning of this
[Music]
I'm nowhere done with this one escapee
room it was not or was it
are they gone
and that's why I wait very patiently for
things to go by so I don't get caught
with my pants down and my ass hanging
out
I hear you up there
hmm that would have killed me
all right good
wait why are you whoa whoa wait a minute
you need to wait wait do I need to okay
I get a funny feeling I need to charge
this up because you were slowing down
real weirdly oh God
hurry up
oh God hurry up hi
okay what am I looking for
gears I think I'm looking for Gears
I think oh gear
gear
grab it grab it grab it
oh my God really
oh shoot
my back
are you no no so what what wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait a minute
wait a minute
[Music]
okay so why couldn't I grab that gear I
wanted to grab the gear and it didn't
let me grab the gear I feel like I
should have been able to grab the gear
but I didn't grab the gear
oh well I'm good
is this thing not announcing my prayer
some kind of [__] oh God
[Music]
hey
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
uh
[Music]
did I charge you up too much was that a
oh
uh
um
[Music]
well this is a problem hey Freddy maybe
we could talk about this maybe oh man
you know wow okay big fan uh huge fan
actually uh big strong fan big big
muscly fan you don't want to mess with
me you don't want to mess with me you
don't want to mess with me oh you think
I'm trapped in here I am
okay so uh if you forget to wind it up
or exceed the wind of Max Capacity we'll
take control oh
block my way to the power oh okay so I
gotta stop being such a worry wart and I
just gotta go get the things
so the code wasn't even like a big Pro
oh
well that's convenient oh
oh well that's convenient all right let
me give you a little slurp
hello hello
worry oh God that's what it is that's
what it do oh my God are you gonna let
go okay you like
you like all right so we're gonna go
this the way I usually do with power
and confidence give there finally okay
well too much power too much confidence
[Music]
so this goes somewhere here
you go
there you go anywhere nowhere there we
go holy [__]
where's chica
[Music]
oh God oh God oh God oh God
that's good that's good
okay this has got to be more
a few more
many more
huh got it perfect oh I'll give it
another wind oh I see another one whoa
whoa whoa whoa
okay there's another one right there
oh is it gonna pop out right there oh
please give me time
[Music]
there we go
oh oh
I thought I heard
oh well this is inconvenient because I
don't know where chica is compared to
everything else I'm listening to The
Music of My Demise
oh chica hurry up
we gotta hurry up hurry up hurry up
hurry up hurry up hurry up hurry up
hurry up
okay
wait oh my God
[Music]
okay that's too much
that sounds normal
okay good okay two more I think
[Music]
oh stop that
somewhere here
there's like two more
easy stuff well I hate that I hate that
I hate that
It's gotta be
fairly obvious
okay I didn't find any that's a not
comforting
[Music]
okay
perfect okay just one more I think just
one more
mayhaps
that's good
okay where in the hell
where in the hell
we're in war where in the hell
boy do you
is it in here maybe nope oh boy oh
didn't know you could be there
okay well this is a problem because
Chico's over there but if I'm far enough
away
I say with confidence me
okay okay okay
holy oh God no that sounds far away
oh God Maybe not maybe not oh my God
it was on the other side
Frick no
nope it's gotta be out on one of these
shelves under it around it somewhere
oh well
[Music]
I can't find it why can't I find it
why can't I find it
that sounds distant
oh God oh God wait oh my God
no
no I'm dead
hey all right yeah that that was my bad
I'm gonna try it again
this time I got it
they're in the same spots
I think I gotta be in the same spot so
I'm missing the same one that I was
before
nobody
so
I just look very careful whoa whoa hey
stop that
stop that it's a small one it's totally
possible to find it
otherwise game broken
it might be broken but
still find it
from there no
in here no
in there oh oh oh oh there it is I got
it I got I got it I got it
I got it
oh my God
[Music]
almost
oh yeah
I'm assuming that's what I needed to do
whoa why
what did that do
Olga
[Music]
oh
[__] I'm in I mean I mean yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes wow wow
well
we've done it
succeeded we seated where everyone else
failed and before I conclude this I'm
gonna take a little peek at what awaits
me in the next episode
well this seems to be a faithful
Recreation a final uh final Freddy's
Freddy Fazbear Five Nights at Freddy's
that's the one I remember what it is
three
okay turn systems off and on use the
levers next to the doors and close them
if the magnetization reaches zero the
door will open due to lack of power
avoid looking at hallucinations they
like to be present but not to be seen
do not leave the office through the
doors he will attack you complete the
puzzles and get out of the room before
someone gets you or something reaches
you what
what
your status problem category critical
sending emergency jokes
sending emergency jokes is there a fast
coin in here can I get a fast coin I
want to play an arcade game that was a
part of it wasn't it you actually had to
play Arcade games huh interesting well
nothing to do it but to do it except
there wasn't a door over here in Five
Nights at Freddy's 3. I remember that
very specifically oh why it's not good
[Music]
interesting
connection lost
well that's not good whoa whoa wait oh
oh that's a problem
what was dread bear doing here okay well
that's gonna end it for this episode I
know it's been a long time since I was
going to get back into this and yes I'm
playing it again so here it is
it took me a while to get back to where
I was supposed to be so expect the next
episode to have a little bit more
substance
actually
no
let me give it one more try let me give
it one more try if I somehow manage to
beat it on one more try
then that's good if I don't then I'm
gonna end it and we'll pick it up at the
next one all right I have no idea what
I'm doing here
uh emergency doors map developer mode
generator status
he this one looks tough
wait a minute that's not what I was
supposed to do
oh
I'm staring at you
I'm turning it back on please thank you
very much I can hide under the desk
that's what they said whoa whoa whoa
whoa what
holy crap
uh one seven seven one nine four four so
I found the code I think
[Music]
one seven seven seven one nine four four
oh do I need to put it in okay one seven
seven one nine four four is that the
Biden 44.
oh
whoa
hey hey
oh yeah look at this that is cool Freddy
you must hurry everyone needs your help
and the souls are in danger go before
it's too late
[Music]
initiating fire protocol
hello there I have a problem I want to
fish in this Lake but it's empty can you
help me I don't know I don't know if I
can
interesting hi can you do me a favor I'm
busy fishing and I would like to get
balloons could you find me some
oh man
oh wait a minute
[Music]